I absolutely like like I think all of us
I think it's impossible not to love the
show the crown the series the [ __ ] and
you portrayed Winston Churchill and
we've talked about this you did a
brilliant job and I thought you really
inhabited Churchill and clearly had to
know a lot about him and kind of become
him to do that role if there was an
alternate universe where Co vid hit and
instead of the current occupant of the
White House we had Winston Churchill how
would he handle it I would say if you
could pick anyone in the entire 20th
century who would do the best possible
job facing our current crisis it would
be Churchill it just look at the
evidence of World War two how he faced
World War two
Churchill was an eccentric man he was
very unpredictable he was difficult in
many senses is possible his politics
were sometimes contemptible but but he
would have attacked this crisis like a
dog with a bone he would not have let a
minute pass in his entire day where he
didn't have some other idea for how to
address a problem and to bring the
country together to do it he was exactly
what England needed in 1940 we so needed
that kind of bullheaded assertiveness we
needed someone who would whom we would
all listen to and Trust at this moment
we didn't have that and so things have
just gotten worse and worse and worse
and well we won't boy what I noticed is
that the Churchill as you portrayed him
and and as as he actually was would
micromanage he would he would have
figured out how we getting these masks
he would have said it is his job of
government to save the people yeah it
would have been all over it
if Churchill had happened to also have a
chain of hotels and resorts for example
the first thing you would have done
would have been to put those at the
disposal of nursing homes so that all
old people could be isolated and taken
care of in comfort and not grouped
together I mean things like that he
would have thought way way outside the
box and he you know those first few days
well I mean in the months before long
months before there were preparations
that had to be made for this moment when
when Trump and company obliterated that
committee that was all set for pandemic
preparedness that was the first colossal
mistake and the mistakes have just
searched tumbled out ever since yeah I
can't we have to be hopeful and reverse
all of them yeah yeah well your book
will help every little bit helps mine
it's like pissing into the wind my book
but you know that's what I do for a
living a great description of your
career pissing into the way that'll be
on my tombstone code